the only other thing I wrote down was
for number six famous sayings evany
every well what accounted the same yeah
I don't know actually at the D and I
hate the text I think everyone's already
hanging over ya know Jo's coming right
now Chris B fan pizza pizza and then we
have the supreme crispy pan pizza for
the supreme lovers here I am the supreme
lover I know that's here you like
supreme a little bit of crunch guess
what we have a sponsorship with this
Jordan oh they actually love that thanks
to you guys for all the support we got a
judge or no sponsorship the best kind of
sponsorship ever we could have ever
asked for it's pizza I grew up eating
DiGiorno and this honestly better than
delivery cuz you get to have it fresh
out of your own oven in your own home
you don't have to worry about no
delivery guy being all rude and saying
no sorry we don't have extra messes I
wish you all the time we don't the deal
with that mr. John we could just make it
ourselves
that timer for 22 minutes okay 22
minutes and here we go and here we go
good morning guys I just woke up to the
most wonderful alarm clock do you guys
hear that Casey got up earlier than me
he's been playing piano I just it's such
a wonderful alarm clock honestly it's
better than the good morning honey thank
you for this wonderful alarm clock
[Music]
exactly yes good morning wonderful
morning a nicely beautiful 18 I love it
is that an original did you write that
yeah well I never wrote it down it's
just it's so nice I just start playing
sometimes and just magic happens you
know I'm saying play it again
so here you should title this
[Music]
I expired
was there a song that inspired you to
write this song it sounds like something
I've heard before somebody tell me for a
movie right yeah yeah I listen to a lot
of movie music so when I naturally play
stuff I'd actually played things that
sound like the front movie you know like
if you're an artist I don't know well if
any artists up there I feel like most
people start emulating things that they
like to watch her listen to her here hmm
that's me yeah I wouldn't know I'm not
an artist yeah you know it's funny we've
had the piano for two weeks and I was
home alone pretty much for like a whole
week cuz then Isaac would go to school
and then like whenever I wasn't shooting
then I'd be home by yourself no but you
know it's funny instead of trying to
play the piano trying to learn the piano
I was watching charmed the whole week
you gotta buy the charm feed song no
just the fact that I wasted all that
time watching some dumb old shows that
of actually using that time wisely to
try to learn you should teach me what's
funny whatever I don't know anyone
though Isaac learned a lot all and song
I think I don't mind it too much I just
learned a hard song like that that's
hard because like you know various
places ya know like you're supposed to
learn music that generally uses only the
white notes first cuz the black notes
it's more jazzy and so it's a little
more like a little more complicated
harder on the ears to pick up so for him
to take up while only I'm like that was
like whoa yeah well I mean I think he's
a natural you might get natural yeah
we're putting image in the classes soon
this panel that we got it's like an
electric piano so it comes with like an
app that you can plug in your iPad to
and then it'll teach you how to play the
song so that actually has lessons and
then there's like lights on the keyboard
itself where it lights up the reason why
we got this piano so I can learn
it's health - but I haven't taken the
time to actually sit down plug the iPad
in and actually learn so yeah I think
slurring the happy birthday song yeah
he's already happy birthday in the hot
one
tink a little star cross ones let me put
this on a tripod you can teach me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
you know the name of the song but in the
Costello cuz we need to know we're dying
to know work look at this cute girl you
almost knocked down the camera cutie pie
[Music]
you're so cute my alright so yeah so
there's people coming over today's we're
doing this little couples game night
okay guys and we've finally doing it cuz
we've been telling our friends that
we're not hunting the host something at
our place cuz our place is like a
perfect hosting splash chill spot yeah
cuz there's like so much room or living
room is so huge we have all the JK
couches these were originally not just
for the office but they ended up not
liking them once they got into the
office so so we bought them off of JK
but yeah so we have like a perfect
hangout spot but we never host anything
like we kind of forgot I feel like our
group of friends we didn't focusing so
much on just working working working
that we forgot to implement the whole us
being friends in real life part like
recently people start having kids
gumpa
flourishing and so yeah we've been we've
been forgetting the Hangout as just
people and friends so we're having
people come over today we're gonna be
doing little game nights I stole all
yeah jinke party games yes we borrowed
the jiggy party games it's so funny
because Joe and I do is for a living but
we're gonna just be having fun tonight
that's a lot of games probably and these
future game nights is happening here
yes we're gonna afford these games yeah
uh if JK let's borrow your charm yeah oh
yeah I'm gonna go get ready now I'm
still in my PJs so are you good morning
buddy
[Music]
cutie you're so fluffy you're so fluffy
humanoid plot you know Q&A don't mm-hmm
he's like new home guys I wanna go to
sleep
would you did in the cup no you messed
up my coat oh I don't know wake up buddy
okay let's go get ready
that's all you ran so fast I actually
want signings on the rear end through
fest you're gonna pinch my butt or
something all right before we forget
again because we've been uploading
recently and we keep forgetting to
mention this every time but thank you
guys so much for 300k on our Channel
yeah we have 300
thousands plus members of our family so
we appreciate you guys so much thank you
thank you alright cool so just got a lot
of work done and the kind of person who
likes to get work done before having fun
or else I'll start guilt-tripping myself
into thinking that I deserve to have fun
I don't deserve to go party luckily I
was a good boy today got my work done
and it is about that time tonight coming
up on that hour where people are gonna
start showing up I'm actually really
excited because I haven't actually hung
out with Joe and Jess Nikki and Stephen
a long time because we're always so busy
we're always busy filming we're always
busy vlogging we're always busy doing
business stuff Rory's busy writing
there's always something you know
work-wise that gets in the way we do see
each other very often in a work setting
and we do have fun while we're working
but we rarely ever meet up though
actually hang out together as friends
without work getting in the way you know
because obviously with work even though
you're having fun there's still a bit of
a pressure and stress factor that comes
into play to just sit back have a few
drinks enjoy some good food good company
play some games I mean that that is very
rare to come by and tonight the stars
have aligned the planets are aligned and
the moon I don't know anyways let's go
see what tips up do so so why am i
holding this pencil still so
oh are you ready are you looking nice
tonight
thank you I like him you put on your shy
girl your cute shy girl always me cuz
I'm too shy to be like owning it you
know I'm just like try owning a real
quick go you haven't noticed already in
horrible under pressure as soon as the
pressures on I came in thank you party
I'm always like and I feel because
there's a couple times or just like
messing around and you tell me try it
dance like Magic Mike or whatever like
you should tell me that and I feel like
cuz I like dancing and I've been told I
could bust a move on the dance floor in
the club but uh but when you put me on
the spot and the lights are on there's
no music and it's like go Casey go I
don't like that I don't want to dance
right now I can't do it it's a lot of
pressure
hey good ready for the party now who
does the Hat no it doesn't I made a mess
there's one crumb yeah big mess let's
preheat the oven
[Music]
[Music]
baby saint-omer yeah I know he is coming
here to make the work what kind of game
should we play it was like these Joe
like that this is literally
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]